[Music]
there's all manner of method to the
madness and our selections is some of
the best scariest horror movies some use
high amounts of gore others deliver
unnerving calm and quiet before
shattering the senses and a few feature
amazing monster makeup and effects
but the one common thread between them
all is that they work and work not just
as producing moments of fear but
sustaining that fear sometimes for
minutes on end to drill deep into our
psyche and stay there for decades these
are the stuff of nightmares what we see
when we close our eyes at night so sit
back relax and boo did we scare ya we're
counting down the best scariest horror
movies ever
[Music]
starting with number 10 wreck
a reporter and her cameraman record the
horrifying outbreak of a disease that
turns humans into vicious cannibals
starring manuela velasco farron terraza
carlos losarte and directed by guame
balaguero and paco plaza critics say
plunging viewers into the nightmarish
hellscape of an apartment complex under
siege wreck proves that found footage
can still be used as an effective
delivery mechanism for sparse economic
horror
i'm
thank you
um
see
number nine hereditary
when the matriarch of the graham family
passes away her daughter and
grandchildren begin to unravel cryptic
and increasingly terrifying secrets
about their ancestry trying to outrun
the sinister fate that they have
inherited starring tony collette millie
shapiro alex wolff and directed by ari
astor critics say hereditary uses its
classic setup as the framework for a
harrowing uncommonly unsettling horror
film whose cool touch lingers long
beyond the closing credits
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
uh
number eight misery
after a serious car crash novelist paul
sheldon is rescued by former nurse annie
wilkes who claims to be his biggest fan
annie brings him to her remote cabin to
recover where her obsession takes a dark
turn when she discovers sheldon is
killing off her favorite character from
his novels as sheldon devises plans for
escape annie grows increasingly
controlling even violent as she forces
the author to shape his writing to suit
her twisted fantasies starring james
khan kathy bates richard farnsworth and
directed by rob reiner critics say
elevated by standout performances from
james khan and kathy bates this taut and
frightening film is one of the best
stephen king adaptations to date i don't
know what you're talking about
ceramic penguin
is this what you're looking for
[Music]
i know you've been out twice paul
first i couldn't figure out how you did
it
but last night
i found your key
[Music]
i know i left my scrapbook out
i can imagine what you might be thinking
of me but you see paul it's all okay
last night it came so clear
i realize you just need more time
eventually you'll come to accept the
idea of being here
paul do you know about the early days at
the kimberley diamond mines
do you know what they did to the native
workers who stole diamonds
don't worry they didn't kill them
that would be like junking your mercedes
just because it had a broken spring no
if they caught them they had to make
sure they could go on working but they
also had to make sure they could never
run away
the operation was called hobbling
annie
[Music]
whatever you think i'm not doing
please don't do it
[Music]
number seven don't look now
still grieving over the accidental death
of their daughter christine john and
laura baxter head to venice italy where
jon's been commissioned to restore a
church there laura meets two sisters who
claim to be in touch with the spirit of
the baxter's daughter now laura takes
him seriously but jon scoffs until he
himself catches a glimpse of what looks
like christine running through the
streets of venice starring julie
christie donald sutherland hillary mason
and directed by nicholas rogue critics
say don't look now patiently build
suspense with haunting imagery and a
chilling score causing viewers to feel
donald sutherland and julie chrissy's
grief deep within
[Music]
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
number six
psycho
phoenix secretary marion crane on the
lam after stealing 40 000
from her employer in order to run away
with her boyfriend sam loomis is
overcome by exhaustion during a heavy
rainstorm traveling on the back roads to
avoid the police she stops through the
night at the ramshackle bates motel and
meets the polite but highly strong
proprietor norman bates a young man with
an interest in taxidermy and a difficult
relationship with his mother starring
anthony perkins janet lee vera miles and
directed by alfred hitchcock critics say
infamous for a shower scene but immortal
for its contribution to the horror genre
because psycho was filmed with tact
grace and art hitchcock didn't just
create modern horror he validated it
so
[Applause]
number five eyes without a face
dr geneseer is riddled with guilt after
an accident that he caused disfigures
the face of his daughter the once
beautiful christian who outsiders
believe is dead dr geneseer along with
accomplice and laboratory assistant
louise kidnaps young women and brings
him to the geneseer mansion after
rendering his victims unconscious dr
geneseer removes their faces and
attempts to graft them onto christians
starring pierre brousseur elita vallee
edith scob and directed by georges
franju critics say a horrific tale of
guilt and obsession eyes without a face
is just as chilling and poetic today as
it was in 1959
[Music]
um
[Music]
guys
oh is he
number four the vanishing
rex and saskia are enjoying a biking
holiday in france when stopping at a gas
station saskia disappears confounded rex
searches everywhere but to no avail
three years later he's still obsessed
with finding her pleading his case on
television putting up posters and
ruining his relationship in the process
eventually an unassuming chemistry
teacher raymond approaches rex
intimating that he knows what happened
starring bernard pierre donadue
jean-bare votes johanna tear siege and
directed by george schleiser critics say
a clinical maddening descent into the
mind of a serial killer and a slowly
unraveling hero culminating with one of
the scariest endings of all time
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
a troubled widow discovers that her son
is telling the truth about a monster
that entered their home through the
pages of a children's book starring
essie davis noah weissman daniel
henshall and directed by jennifer kent
critics say the babadook relies on real
horror rather than cheap jump scares and
boasts a heartfelt genuinely moving
story to booty
[Music]
so
[Music]
glass and mirror attachment clean and
polish shower doors or mirrors for a
streak-free shine as part of this
steaming special we'll even include the
garmin
number two jaws
when a young woman is killed by a shark
while skinny dipping near the new
england tourist town of amity island
police chief martin brody wants to close
the beaches but mayor larry vaughn
overrules him fearing that the loss of
tourist revenue will [ __ ] the town
ichthyologist matt hooper and grizzled
ship captain quint offer to help brody
capture the killer beast and the trio
engage in an epic battle of man vs
nature starring roy scheider robert shaw
richard dreyfuss and directed by steven
spielberg critics say compelling
well-crafted storytelling and a
judicious sense of terror ensures steven
spielberg's jaws has remained a
benchmark in the art of delivering
modern blockbuster thrills
[Applause]
come on in the water
take it easy take it easy
[Music]
uh
[Applause]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
the blair witch project
found video footage tells the tale of
three film students who've traveled to a
small town to collect documentary
footage about the blair witch a
legendary local murderer over the course
of several days the students interviewed
townspeople and gathered clues to
support the tales veracity but the
project takes a frightening turn when
the students lose their way in the woods
and begin hearing horrific noises
starring heather donahue michael c
williams joshua leonard and directed by
daniel myrick and eduardo sanchez
critics say full of creepy campfire
scares mock doc the blair witch project
keeps audiences in the dark about its
titular villain proving once more that
imagination can be as scary as anything
on screen
uh
huh
oh jesus christ let me get my jeans on
take the video camera no get the duck
ready
go go
hurry up i'm coming
my boots are at least
oh my god what the [ __ ]
is that
[Laughter]
the descent
a year after a severe emotional trauma
sarah goes to north carolina to spend
some time exploring caves with her
friends after descending underground the
women find strange cave paintings and
evidence of an earlier expedition then
learned that they are not alone
underground predators inhabit the
crevices and they have a taste for human
flesh starring shauna mcdonald natalie
mendoza alex reed and directed by neil
marshall critics say death direction and
strong performances from its all-female
cast guide the descent a riveting
claustrophobic horror
film yeah
ah
[Applause]
ah
[Applause]
the exorcist
one of the most profitable horror movies
ever made this tale of an exorcism is
based loosely on actual events when
young reagan starts acting odd
levitating speaking in tongues her
worried mother seeks medical help only
to hit a dead end a local priest however
thinks the girl may be seized by the
devil the priest makes a request to
perform an exorcism and the church sends
in an expert to help with a difficult
job starring ellen burstein linda blair
max von sydow and directed by william
friedkin critics say the exorcist rides
its supernatural theme to magical effect
with remarkable special effects and an
eerie atmosphere resulting in one of the
scariest films of all time
let your mighty hand cast him out of
your servant reagan to raise mcneil
so he may no longer captive this person
[Music]
in your image
and to redeem through your son
who lives and reigns with you in the
unity of the holy spirit god forever and
ever
amen lord hear my prayer
[Music]
[Music]
damian the response please tell me
don't let my cry come unto thee
almighty lord
word of god the father jesus christ god
the lord of all creation
gave to your holy apostles the power to
turn underfoot serpents and scorpions
grant me
[Music]
your unworthy servant pardon for all
and the power to confront this cruel
people
and finally number one alien
in deep space the crew of the commercial
starship nostromo is awakened from their
cryosleep capsules halfway through their
journey home to investigate a distressed
call from an alien vessel the terror
begins when the crew encounters a nest
of eggs inside the alien ship an
organism from inside an egg leaps out
and attaches itself to one of the crew
causing him to fall into a coma starring
tom skerritt sigourney weaver john hurt
and directed by ridley scott critics say
a modern classic alien blends science
fiction horror and bleak poetry into a
seamless hole
you sure look look around i'm sure that
it's not there i mean it's got to be
around there somewhere
check that out
you may be getting interference
dallas are you sure there is no sign of
it
there
it's got to be around there
dallas
[Music]
uh
am i i'm not claire lamb but i want to
get the hell out of here
oh god it's moving right towards you
um
[Music]
well friends that about does it for us
be sure to stay tuned to the rotten
tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love and for
even more news scores and
recommendations on the latest tv shows
and movies go to runtomatos.com until
next time i'm your host snaz perez and
we'll see you back here for more top 10s
on the rotten tomatoes countdown
[Music]
you